[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم صعد تنظيم القاعده في جزيره
العرب من هجماته ضد الحوثيين في مناطق
يمنيه مختلفه خلال الساعات ال الماضيه
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر نناقشه في محوريين
هل يمكن ان تكون هذه الهجمات ايذانا ببدء
فصل جديد من المواجهات بين القاعده
والحوثيين في
اليمن ما مدى تاثير مناخ التوتر الراهن في
صنعاء على اصطفافات القوى السياسيه
والاجتماعيه في المواجهه بين القاعده
[موسيقى]
والحوثيين لم يكد الحوثيون يسيطرون على
مفاصل العاصمه اليمنيه صنعاء حتى نفذ
تنظيم القاعده تهديده بتصعيد الهجمات ضدهم
في مناطق مختلفه من البلاد وكان التنظيم
قد دعى اهل السنه لحمل السلاح لمواجهه
الحوثيين وتثير هجمات الحوثيين على مؤسسات
ومنشات مختلفه في صنعاء وعلى منازل خصومهم
السياسيين المخاوف من انزلاق الامور الى
صراع طائفي في بلد عرف تاريخيا بالتعايش
بين كافه مذاهبه وفئاته وقد اعربت العربيه
السعوديه عن مخاوف من ان يعطي الوضع
الحالي في اليمن القاعده والحوثيين مجالا
لتعريض امن البلاد ودول الجوار
للخطر وللصراحة
عناصر دراميه صغيره تنتهي الى ما هو ديني
كبير واشارات صراع سياسي يهدر ما هو
اجتماعي ويز دريه فاي زمن هو ذاك الذي لم
تكن للمراه اليمنيه عصمه فيه لكن الجماعه
نفسها التي انتهكت العاصمه على ما يذهب
خصومهم واهانتها وجيشها لم تعد تكترث لعص
مكونات هذا المجتمع ما دام الهدف ابدال
حال ب
وسلطه باخرى قبل ذلك تعرضت جامعات ومؤسسات
مدنيه اخرى للقصف واقتحمت بيوت واوقف على
الحواجز مواطنون راوا في الحضور الحوثي
احتلالا واهانه للمنظومه السياسيه
والاجتماعيه القائمه في البلاد منذ
عقود وسبق ذلك كله تهجير من وصفوا
بالسلفيين من دماج وكان ذلك قبل سيطره
الحوثيين على عمران والجوف ما زاد الشعور
بان مكونا بعينه مستهدف بالقتل والتهجير
وتلقي الاهانات دون ان تحرك الدوله ساكنه
تراكم هذا وسواه انتج بيئه تعادي الحوثيين
وتحتضن في الوقت نفسه اي طرف قوي يقترح
نفسه في مواجهتهم ومن غير تنظيم القاعده
يفعل وقد فعل بهجمات عده استهدفت الحوثيين
في الاونه الاخيره استبق تنظيم ذلك ببيان
خاطب فيه عموم اليمنيين دعاهم بالسنه
وطالبهم بالتوحد وحمل السلاح والكفاح
وتوعد بنثر اشلاء الحوثيين وجعل رؤوسهم
تتطاير وقال انهم يستكملون ما وصفه
بالمشروع الرافضي الفارسي وان على السنه
احباط هذا المشروع شرط الا يقع في خطا
العراقيين حين امنوا للعبه السياسيه
القائمه على المحاصه
الطائفيه في الحاله العراقيه التي اشار
اليها تنظيم القاعده تحول سنه البلاد الى
طائفه وبعد حمله عسكريه مديده على الانبار
انتهى الامر ببعض شيوخ العشائر هناك الى
التحالف مع تنظيم الدوله بعد تراكم
المظالم وعجز الدوله وهي الخصم والحكم
هناك عن تفكيكها فاذا البلاد امام خيارين
كلاهما مر تسلط الحكومات وتشدد الجماعات
وما بين انهما من قوى مدنيه ضحيه لهذا
الاستقطاب موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيفين
من صنعاء عبد الغني الماوري الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي وامين عام مجلس شباب
الثوره اليمنيه ومن بيروت عبد الحافظ معجب
الاعلامي والمحلل السياسي اهلا
بضيفي الكريمين السيد عبد الغني هل ما
نشاهده الان من مقدمات ما يجري تحديدا بين
القاعده وبين الحوثيين هو اسوا سيناريو
يخشاه اليمنيون تراجع للدوله اليمنيه
الدوله الوطنيه في مقابل ظهور ما يمكن
توصيفه بحاله مذهبيه واستقطاب مذهبي في
اليمن بالطبع يعني اسوا شيء يمكن ان
يتخيله اليمنيون ان تموت السياسه ويكون
هناك فقط جماعات العنف كان من المتوقع وان
الحوثيين قد اجتاحوا صنعاء ان يكون هناك
رد من جماعات عنف اخرى هذا ما نقصده عندما
تموت السياسه يكون الكلمه عندها لجماعات
العنف اتمنى من الحوثيين ان يدركوا هذا
الامر لا يمكن وهم يستعرضون بسلاحهم في
صنعاء وفي صعدا وفي عمران ان تكون الحاله
طبيعيه لابد ان ينشى هناك جماعات عنف فما
بالك و تنظيم القاعده موجود في اليمن
ويمارس ارهابا على الاقل يجب ان يستفيد
الحوثيين من هذه النقطه المجتمع اليمني
الى حد الان رغم مرارته مما فعله الحوثيين
وانهم احتلوا صنعاء حقيقه رغم ذلك فانهم
يرفضون تدخل القاعده هم يدركون ان القاعده
ايضا مشروع خطر على اليمن وعلى السلم
الاهلي القاعده هو مشروع شرير لكن يجب هذا
او هذا مرهون ايضا بالتصرفات التي يجب ان
يقدم عليها الحوثيين وهم ان يتراجعوا
خطوتين وثلاث خطوات الى الوراء وان لا
يمضوا بمشروعهم العسكري الى الامام لان
ذلك سيكون تهديدا للدوله والكيان على حد
سواء سيد عبد الحافظ الى اي مدى يتحمل
الحوثيون بما فعلوه في اعطاء مبرر تبرير ل
القاعده او اي استعمال للعنف الحاله
اليمنيه اولا يجب علينا ان نشرع لما يفعله
تنظيم القاعده من جرائم بحجه ان ما فعله
انصار الله في العاصمه صنعاء هو اوجد بيئه
حاضنه لتنظيم القاعده كلنا يتفق وكلنا
يدرك ان تنظيم القاعده هو فزاعه يستخدمها
البعض فقط من اجل احراز مكاسب سياسيه
وتقدم سياسي معين تنظيم القاعده اليوم ظهر
في محافظه البيضاء عباره عن رد على اسقاط
الفرقه الاولى مدرع ليس اكثر الكل يعرف من
اين جاء تنظيم القاعده الى اليمن والكل
يعرف جرائم تنظيم القاعده ونشاط تنظيم
القاعده ومن يمول تنظيم القاعده ومن يحركه
بالريموت كنترول هلك تب القاعده اليوم
يتحرك وفق اجنده معينه نعم هل لك ان
تبلغنا من الذي يحرك القاعده بالريموت
كنترول نعم اليوم يحركها اللواء الفار علي
محسن الاحمر وقد راينا يوم امس داخل معسكر
الفرقه الاولى المنحله راينا داخلها معامل
تصنيع المتفجرات وراينا
داخلها العده التي كان يستخدمها تنظيم
القاعده وراينا ايضا داخل مبنى جامعه
الايمان التابعه لرجل الدين الشيخ عبد
المجيد الزنداني هؤلاء الذين سقطوا في ال
ليس هذا هروبا هروبا عفوا ليس هذا هروبا
من تحمل المسؤوليه من قبل جماعه الحوثي هي
التي استعملت السلاح ضيفنا من صنعاء يقول
بانها احتلت العاصمه صنعاء وبالتالي بما
يواجه السلاح ان لم يكن بحركه
تشبهه يعني اذا وصفنا بان انصار الله
سيطروا على العاصمه صنعاء بالسلاح كما
تفضلت نسمح لتنظيم القاعده ان ياتي ليسيطر
على بقيه المحافظات بالسلاح هل هل هل
نساوي من تحركوا باسم الثوره الشعبيه وباو
جاع الشعب اليمني نساويه بالقتله
والمجرمين من تنظيم القاعده هل نستطيع ان
نقارن بين التنظيمين بين حركه شبابيه
سياسيه لنصره المستضعفين وللنصر المظلومين
وللوقوف مع الشعب اليمني نساويها بتنظيم
القاعده الارهابي الذي يقتل المواطنين سنه
وشيعه ومن كل الفصائل هل نستطيع ان نوازي
بين انصار الله الذين حفظوا كرامه الجنود
اليمنيين وعزز وهم وكرمو حتى عندما كانوا
اس في ايديهم وعناصر تنظيم القاعده التي
قطعت رقابهم وذبحت على قارعه الطريق على
مراه ومسمع من مؤسسات الدوله لا هنا هنا
ظلم كبير ان نساوي بين الفر رايته ظلم
كبير سيد عبد الحظ هنا سؤالي موجه للسيد
عبد الغني فيما يتعلق بهذه المقاربه هذه
الثنائيه الان كما يقول ضيفنا من بيروت
هناك حاله من الشرعيه بما يفعله الحوثيون
في اليمن في المقابل لا يجب اعطاء اي
تبرير ل ما تفعله
القاعده جيد جيد جيد جدا انا ساقول عده
حقائق اولا لا يوجد عاقل يمكنه الدفاع عن
تنظيم القاعده لم يحصل ولن يحصل اننا سوف
ندافع عن تنظيم القاعده مهما حصل لان
تنظيم القاعده كما قلت لك هو مشروع شرير
هذا اولا لنبعد هذه النقطه عن المزايده
وعن الكلام الذي لا يفيد الامر الثاني ان
انصار الله هم مكون اساسي
مهم سياسي في البلد هذا صحيح حاله شعبيه
هذا صحيح ولكن ايضا هو ميليشيا مسلحه ماذا
يمكن ان نسمي ان هناك مجموعه من المسلحين
يسيطرون على البلد يداهمون المؤسسات
البيوت يفعلون كل شيء خارج اطار القانون
ياخذون الاسلحه ينهبون الدبابات ماذا يمكن
ان نسمي هذه الحاله هل يمكن ان نسمي هذه
الحاله انها شرعيه انها طبيعيه انه امور
عاديه هل يمكن ان نسمي ذلك بهذا الشكل انا
قلت ان ان انصار الله هم جزء من الشعب
اليمني وعليهم ان يدركوا ان يدركوا ان
يدركوا ان ان امساكهم بالسلاح ان عدم
انخراطهم في السياسه يغذي هذه الجماعات
الارهابيه هذه مساله في غايه الاهميه انا
لا استطيع ان ان اناشد تنظيم القاعده و ان
اطالبه بان يكون عاقلا لكنني يمكنني ان ان
اناشد او ان اتحدث او ان اكلم او ان اطالب
او ان اندد بانصار الله لانهم مكون سياسي
في الاخير وهم شاركوا في مؤتمر الحوار لكن
عليهم ان يتوقفوا عند الحاله السياسيه انا
ساكون في غايه التعاسه لو انه شطب انصار
الله من المعادله اليمنيه سواء السياسيه
او الشعبيه لانهم غنى لانهم جزء من هذا
الشعب لكن دون سلاح يا عزيزي السلاح حكر
للدوله عدا ذلك سنكون في في في شيء يسمى
يسمى عصابات يسمى جماعات لا يسمى دوله
ياقد هذه هذه الفكره سيد عبد الغني لاسال
ضيفي عن ما يوجه من انتقادات لانصار الله
او للحوثيين من هذه الازدواجيه في الخطاب
تقول بان عناصر الحوثيين قد حافظوا على
كرامه الجندي اليمني ولكن اي كرامه و
صنعاء تجتاح بالسلاح وتقتحم بيوت وينام في
اسره اطفال وتعرض كرامات الناس للاهانه بل
وتحاصر نسوى داخل جمعيه اين كل هذه
السلوكات من الخطاب الذي يقول عنه
الحوثيون الا انتم يعني بما يفعله عفوا
ليس انتم ولكن ما يفعله الحوثييون يعطي
التبرير للقاعده بالدرجه
الاولى اخي عبد القادر يجب ان ان تدرك
جيدا ان ما يحدث اليوم في صنعاء من اعمال
فرديه ليست ليست بالضروره ان تكون من من
صنع انصار الله ومن ومن فعل انصار الله
الحوثيين هل رايتم احد من قيادات او من
اعضاء انصار الله تصور في كما تفضلت في
اسره الاطفال او اقتحم البيوت انصار الله
يا اخي الكريم حافظوا على المؤسسات
الرسميه للدوله وحافظوا على بيوت كبار
المعارضين وسلموها لهم ما عدا بيوت هؤلاء
الذين فروا من البلد وهم مطلوبين الان
للعداله باستثناء نتحدث عن اولاد الاحمر
واللواء علي محسن الاحمر اما
بالنسبه لبيوت المواطنين ولحرم المواطنين
فاللجنة للمواطنين يجب ان نكون منصفين في
هذا الامر انصار الله اليوم يحمون البنوك
ويحمون مؤسسات الدوله انصار الله عندما
اسقطوا الاسبوع الماضي الكثير من مؤسسات
الدوله ومن المعسكرات التي سلمها لهم
قيادات هذه المعسكرات طواعيه واعلنوا
انخراطهم في الثوره الشبابيه الشعبيه
السلميه قاموا بتسليم هذه المؤسسات للشرطه
العسكريه واخذوا بها استلامات واضحه انصار
الله حافظوا على الدوله لم يسقطوا الدوله
حافظوا عليها جيدا بصفتهم من يقومون بكل
هذه
لها جيش ولها شرطه ولها دوله قائمه من
يعطي الحق للحوثيين بان يقوموا بما يقومون
به الان حتى يزيدوا بانهم يقفون جنبا الى
جنب ان كانت طبعا الصوره
صحيحه نعم انصار الله انخرطوا في مؤتمر
الحوار الوطني وكان هذا نشاط سياسي لهم
تعرضوا للاغتيالات تعرضوا للمضايقات
تعرضوا للظلم كثيرا ولكنهم ظلوا محافظين
على النشاط السياسي السلمي جاءت الثوره
الشبابيه الان الثوره الشعبيه في العام سي
عب ع الح سؤ سؤال عفوا
سؤ تحرك انصار المس بسي المسه بسيطه اث
الثوره
السلميه سلميه على اث الثوره السلميه التي
انخرط فيها انصار الله وجب عليهم الحفاظ
على مؤسسات الد اذا كانت الصوره بهذا
الشكل و سؤالي موجه للسيد عبد الغني فيما
يتعلق الان بما هو مطروح نوع النقاش
الموجود الان لدى النخب السياسيه في اليمن
عن الاصطفافات التي تشكلت والتغير الي طرا
في الخارطه السياسيه في اليمن بعد الذي
جرى وقام به الحوثيون هل مازال وضع على
حاله ام تغيرت الرؤيه وتغيرت ربما
الاساليب في طريقه
المعالجه بعد ثوره 11 فبراير كانت ثقافه
السلم والتغيير عن طريق السلم هي الاساس
لكن ما فعله الحوثي الان ان الامر انقلب
على السلميه الان نحن نشهد في اليمن تراجع
لمعنى السلام لمعنى السلميه هناك مسلحين
في كل مكان يا اخي هو يتح حدث عن منزلين
او ثلاثه منازل استاذ عبد القادر هناك
عشرات المنازل هناك عشرات الجمعيات مؤسسه
اليتيم تم نهبها جمعيه امان للكفيفات ايضا
مؤسسات اخرى يتحدث عن بيت علي محسن وك
سلميه كوسيله كحل التراجع لدى من سيد عبد
الغني يا اخي لم نرى في لم نرى لم ن لم
نرى انصار الله كل ما رايناه الى الان في
اليمن هم لصوص الله لكن فيما يتعلق في
موضوع الذي تح تحدثت فيه عن السياسه
والمجال والمشهد السياسي في اليمن هو
متوقف لان السلاح عندما يكون السلاح هو
الذي يستولي على العاصمه فان السياسه تسقط
تخرص لا احد يتحدث الرئيس كانه لم الرئيس
والوزراء والنواب والاحزاب ليسوا موجودين
يا اخي الكلمه الان هي للمسلحين
فقط على كل بعد فاصل قصير سوف نفصل في هذا
التحول الذي يحصل في الخارطه السياسيه في
اليبن في مساله التعاطي مع الحل السلمي او
ربما الانحدار الى استعمال وسائل اخرى
بالنظر لما يحدث في هذا البلد من تطورات
بعد
[موسيقى]
الفاصل اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش ابعاد تصعيد تنظيم القاعده في
جزيره العرب من هجماته على الحوثيين في
عده مناطق ب اليمن واجد تحيه ليفي من
بيروت وكذلك من صنعاء سيد عبد الحافظ ضيفي
من بيروت الى الان هناك تعطل في تسميه
رئيس للوزراء في اليمن والسبب احجام
السياسيين والطبقات السياسيه عن ان يرضخوا
لهذه المساله تحت سيطره و سيطره السلاح
وسيطره الحوثيين وفرض شروطهم هذا المازق
السياسي ايضا الا يحيل الى ماات اخرى
عنوانها الاساسي هو العنف في ايجاد الحلول
نعم لا اعتقد ان العنف كان يوما من الايام
حل لاي مشكله من المشاكل الموجوده على ارض
الواقع ولكن المشكله اليوم ليست في مساله
السلاح الذي بيد انصار الله والكل يعلم
السلاح المتوفر والمتواجد بيد المكونات
السياسيه الاخرى والتي هي ايضا شريك وطرف
في اتفاق السلم والشراكه لكن المشكله
اليوم في صنعاء هي مشكله ان هناك طرف سقط
ولا يزال يترنح حتى هذه اللحظه هناك طرف
لازال مؤثرا في الساحه هناك ايضا طرف ثالث
يتربص بالمشهد اليمني وينتظر فقط مغادره
اللجان الشعبيه وانصار الله من العاصمه
صنعاء لاحداث الفوضى واغراق البلاد في
الفوضه وانا من هنا اناشد الاخوه انصار
الله واللجان الشعبيه الا يتركوا العاصمه
صنعاء قبل احلال السلام النهائي والكامل
داخل العاصمه صنعاء والوصول الى مرحله
الاستقرار النهائي لان الشعب اليمني لن
يرحمهم الشعب اليمني سيقول ان انصار الله
انتصروا في هذه الثوره ولكنهم سلموها
للصوص ونهاب ومجرمين وقطاع طرق سيفعلون
بالعاصمه ما لا يحمد عقباه وجود انصار
الله اليوم كقوه وكطر يحمل السلاح داخل
العاصمه صنعاء لتامين العاصمه ومؤسساتها
ومنشات امر ضروري ولا اعتقد ان هناك ضير
في هذا الامر مساله نزع السلاح ومساله
السلاح الثقيل نحن متفقين جميعا كيمنيين
ان بموجب مخرجات مؤتمر الحوار الوطني سيتم
نزع السلاح من كافه الاطراف السياسيه التي
تحمل السلاح الثقيل وسيتم تسليمه للدوله
التي ينشد اليمنيين اليوم الدوله التي لا
تزال غائبه حتى اليوم الدوله التي هي غير
موجوده حتى اليوم يجب الان على الاطراف
السياسيه ان تبدي صدق النوايا وان تتحرك
باتجاه تنفيذ بنود اتفاقيه السلم والشراكه
لاحلال الامن والسلام داخل العاصمه صنعاء
اسمع اسمع تعليق عفوا اسمع تعليق السيد
عبد الغني ضيفي في صنعاء عن ما ذكره تفضل
به ضيفي من بيروت فيما يتعلق بهذه الرؤيه
السياسيه وعن دور الحوثيين بالاتجاه سلما
وليس تكريس مساله العنف
كحل يعني ميليشيا مسلحه وتريدون ان تقنعو
انها انها يعني
جماعه السلميه يعني هذا امر يعني غريب جدا
على كل حال لنكن واقعيين انا اريد ان اسال
ال 150 دبابه التي استولوا عليها هل هي
ملك علي
محسن طيب واذا كانت ملك ملك الجيش اليمني
لنفترض انها ملك علي محسن الا يجدر
بالحوثيين ان يسلموها للدوله هذا امر مهم
للغايه يا اخي ببساطه لا تكن لي مؤتمر
الحوار ولا مخرجاته بديهيات الدول بديهيه
البديهيه الاولى ان السلاح حكر على الدوله
الدوله هي التي تحتكر السلاح انا اريد من
انصار الله ان تكون حاله سياسيه واجتماعيه
وحسب لا اريد اكثر من ذلك ساموت معهم
سادافع عنهم ع سنكون معهم الشعب اليمني
جميعا لكن السياسه فقط في يت فيما يتعلق
بهذه الثنائيه في الحل بين الحل السياسي
وبين التعقيد الامني عفوا فقط اكمل سؤالي
لو سمحت سيد عبد الغني الان فيما يتعلق
بخطاب القاعده وتعقيدات المشهد اليمني بعد
الذي حدث من الحوثيين هل هناك امكانيه
مجال ان يصبح لحديث القاعده ووقعه لدى
اليمنيين سواء كانوا كمجموعات في اطار
احزاب سياسيه او تنظيمات او اطار قبلي او
اطار فردي يجد له وقع يختلف ع ما كان على
الوضع قبل ما فعله في
صنعاء نعم القاعده نبه
شيطانيه تنظيم القاعده سؤالي عبد الغني لو
تفضلت القاعده في اليمن معروف لدى
اليمنيين جميعا انها كانت تحرك بايادي
سياسيه يعني في المجمل ولكن وعلى كل حال
اليمنيين لا يمكن ان يدرجوا الى خطاب
القاعده لان خطاب القاعده هو خطاب تدميري
نحن صحيح ضد تواجد ميليشيا الحوثي داخل
صنعاء ضد احتلالهم ضد اقتحامهم للبيوت لكن
هذا الامر لا يمكن لا يمكن ان يجعلنا ان
ننساق وراء القاعده لان القاعده كما قلت
لك مشروع شرير وانا كما الاحظ من جميع
التيارات السياسيه المناهضه للحوثي انهم
لا يؤمنون بخطاب القاعده يع يعرفون تماما
ان خطاب القاعده ومشروع القاعده هو موت
للجميع ولا احد يريد ان يموت في هذا البلد
ا سيد عبد الحافظ فيما يتعلق بما قد يؤثر
عليه تداعيات الوضع في اليمن وهذه
الثنائيه الاخذه في البروز الحوثيين من
جهه وخطاب القاعده الموجه للحوثيين من جهه
اخرى يقلق جيران اليمن وبالاساس المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الا الم يعطي الحوثيون
الحجه بالضروره للقاعده حتى تقوم بما تقوم
به الان وبالتالي تشكل خطر ليس فقط على
اليمن ولكن حتى على
جيرانها نعم دعنا نفصل المساله بوضوح
الحوثيون اليوم اسقطوا مركز مهم من مراكز
الفساد والارهاب في اليمن اذا لماذا
القاعده اليوم تطل براسها هل القاعده
حزينه على اللواء علي محسن الاحمر مثلا هل
القاعده حزينه على جامعه الايمان هل
القاعده حزينه اليوم على تجمع الاصلاح
الاخوان المسلمين ما علاقه تنظيم القاعده
بما يحدث اليوم اس
الف مشروع سياسي اسقاط الفساد واسقاط الذي
مثلته في سيد علي محسن يكون بالتحالف مع
انصار الرئيس المخلو علي عبد الله
صالح لا اعتقد ان هناك تحالف مع انصار
المخلوع علي عبد الله صالح وعلي عبد الله
صالح يجب ان يحاكم اليوم بمجرد سقوط
المبادره الخليجيه وسقوط الحصانه علي عبد
الله صالح يجب ان يحاكم و وان يسائل عن
الجرائم التي ارتكبها طيله الفتره الماضيه
لا اعتقد ان ثم ثائر يتضامن او يتحالف مع
مجرم وقاتل هذا الامر مستبعد
تماما الامر هذا مستحيل ليس مستبعد وحسب
ولكن تنظيم القاعده عندما يطل براسه اليوم
للدفاع عن اطراف تهاوت وسقطت سيكون يكون
نهايته قريبه وانا اعتقد ان ابناء محافظه
البيضاء او حضرموت اذا خرجوا لينتصر
لنفسهم امام تنظيم القاعده اذا خرجوا
لمواجهه تنظيم القاعده الله سبحانه وتعالى
سينصر
وسيينا والغلبه دائما هي للشعوب هي
للمستضعفين هي المظلومين مهما مهما فعلت
تنظيم القاعده الجريمه التي ارتكبتها امس
الاول كانت جريمه بشعه جدا في محافظه
البيضاء عندما قامت بقتل خمسه مواطنين فقط
بتهمه انهم ينتمون لحركه انصار الله
قتلتهم ومن ثم حرقتهم حتى فحم جثثهم هذه
الجريمه لاقت استياء واسع في في اوساط
المجتمع اليمني واعتقد ان ابناء اليمن اذا
تحركوا تحرك شعبي حقيقي لمواجهه تنظيم
القاعده وانصار الشريعه سينتصرون باذن
الله سبحانه وتعالى سيد عبد الغني هناك
مقاربات عديده بين ما جرى في اليمن وبين
الحاله العراقيه التي افضت في النهايه الى
نشوء وتطور تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه في
العراق وفي الشام هل الحاله اليمنيه ايضا
ماضيه في هذا الاتجاه خاصه هناك كثير من
ردود الفعل الاقليميه والدوليه تحذر من
هذا
المسلك لا اعتقد انه بهذه الصيغه ان تنظيم
القاعده يمكنه ان يتمدد في اليمن الحاله
اليمنيه مختلفه لكن انا ما اخشى ان ان
يصبح الرد الوحيد او العمل الوحيد المشروع
في اليمن هو العمل المسلح هذا ما يقلقني
لانه في النهايه ممكن ان ينشا جماعات مسلح
لا علاقه لها بالقاعده يعني ويكون ايضا
اتجاه اتجاه ضد انصار الله او ضد يعني هذه
هي المساله التي تقلقني لكن انا في تنظيم
القاعده لا اظن ان يمنيا عاقلا سيقف معها
ومع مشروعها يجب ان يعلم انصار الله انهم
ليكونوا معنا يجب ان يتخلوا عن السلاح اذا
تخلوا عن السلاح فاننا سنمضي الى الامام
لكن اذا تمسكوا بالسلاح وبالعام جيه وبالغ
وباحت لال صنعاء وباحت لال المناطق والان
يذهبون الى الحديده فان الكل الشرور
ستندلع في اليمن يا اخي الوحده الو الوحده
اليمنيه في خطر الجمهوريه في خطر كل شيء
في خطر يعني لنكن عاقلين لديهم ماخذ على
علي محسن على بيت الاحمر على على على هذه
مجالها القانون مجالها القضاء وليس مجالها
الميليشيات المسلحه يجب ان يفهم ويدرك
انصار الله هذه الحقيقه ما لم فان اليمن
مقبله على سنيورات كارثيه لان السلاح
سيكون هو المنطق لن يكون هناك منطق سوى
السلاح للاسف اشكرك اشكرك ادرك ان الوقت
كنت معنا من صنعاء عبد الغني الماوري
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي وامين عام مجلس
شباب الثوره اليمنيه وكذلك اشكر ضيفنا من
بيروت عبد الحافظ معجب الاعلامي والمحلل
السياسي وبهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه
جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد دمتم
[موسيقى]
بخير
ه